[Music]
over the course of our lifetimes our
bodies undergo a series of extraordinary
metamorphosis we grow experience puberty
and many of us reproduce behind the
scenes the endocrine system works
constantly to orchestrate these changes
alongside growth and sexual maturity
this system regulates everything from
your sleep to the rhythm of your beating
heart exerting its influence over each
and every one of your cells the
endocrine system relies on interactions
between three features to do its job
glands hormones and trillions of cell
receptors firstly there are several
hormone producing glands three in your
brain and seven in the rest of your body
each is surrounded by a network of blood
vessels from which they extract
ingredients to manufacture dozens of
hormones those hormones are then pumped
out in tiny amounts usually into the
bloodstream from there each hormone
needs to locate a set of target cells in
order to bring about a specific change
to find its targets it's helped along by
receptors which are special proteins
inside or on the cells surface those
receptors recognize specific hormones as
they walked by and bind to them when
this happens that hormone receptor
combination triggers a range of effects
that either increase or decrease
specific processes inside the cell to
change the way that cell behaves by
exposing millions of cells at a time to
hormones in carefully regulated
quantities the endocrine system drives
large-scale changes across the body take
for instance the thyroid and the two
hormones it produces triiodothyronine
and thyroxine these hormones travel to
most of the body's cells where they
influence how quickly those cells use
energy and how rapidly they work in turn
that regulates everything from breathing
rate to heartbeat body temperature and
digestion hormones also have some of
their most visible and familiar effects
during puberty in men puberty begins
when the testes starts
secreting testosterone that triggers the
gradual development of the sexual organs
makes facial hair sprout and causes the
voice to deepen and height to increase
in women estrogen secreted from the
ovaries signals the start of adulthood
it helps the body develop makes the hips
widen and thickens the wombs lining
preparing the body for menstruation or
pregnancy an enduring misconception
around the endocrine system is that
there are exclusively male and female
hormones in fact men and women have
estrogen and testosterone just in
different amounts both hormones play a
role in pregnancy as well alongside more
than 10 other hormones that ensure the
growth of the fetus enable birth and
help the mother feed her child such
periods of hormonal change are also
associated with fluctuations in mood
that's because hormones can influence
the production of certain chemicals in
the brain like serotonin when chemical
levels shift they may cause changes in
mood as well but that's not to say that
hormones have unlimited power over us
they're frequently viewed as the main
drivers of our behavior making us slaves
to their effects especially during
puberty but research shows that our
behavior is collectively shaped by a
variety of influences including the
brain and its neurotransmitters our
hormones and various social factors the
primary function of the endocrine system
is to regulate our bodily processes not
control us sometimes disease stress and
even diet can disrupt that regulatory
function however altering the quantity
of hormones that glands secrete or
changing the way that cells respond
diabetes is one of the most common
hormonal disorders occurring when the
pancreas secretes too little insulin a
hormone that manages blood sugar levels
and hypo and hyper thyroidism occur when
the thyroid gland makes too little or
too much thyroid hormone when there's
too little thyroid hormone that results
in a slowed heart rate fatigue and
depression and when there's too much
thyroid hormone weight loss
sleeplessness
and irritability but most of the time
the endocrine system manages to keep our
bodies in a state of balance and through
its constant regulation it drives the
changes that ultimately help us become
who we are if you want to learn more
about the ins and outs of the human body
start with this playlist or subscribe to
our channel to keep your finger on the
pulse
[Music]